i have to tell you and reiterate that we
are
very concerned uh by the prc's
provocative military activity near
taiwan
tension certainly is growing between
china and taiwan and that in turn is
prompting a new debate about whether the
u.s needs a new policy approach to
prevent china from making a move on
taiwan an act that could start a wider
war in asia and between the u.s and
china specifically as we said
the activity is destabilizing
it risks miscalculation
uh and it has the potential to undermine
regional peace and stability china of
course considers taiwan a breakaway
province that should be made part of
china
taiwan
jungle
that has been china's position for a
long time though beyond rhetoric it
hasn't taken steps to actually forcibly
swallow up taiwan in the last year or so
though and particularly in the last few
months china has been acting more like a
country that might use its growing and
increasingly sophisticated military to
move on taiwan and attempt to force it
to unify china has sent repeated flights
of its military aircraft near taiwan
including many in areas taiwan considers
part of its air defense perimeter the
flights have been growing both larger in
number and more frequent
there have also been stepped up chinese
naval actions and recently satellite
photos showed china building up its
three air bases closest to taiwan
this obviously concerns taiwan but it's
also of direct concern to the u.s in
fact it's caused some analysts to argue
that it's time for the u.s to abandon
the approach it's taken in addressing
taiwanese concerns that approach is
called strategic ambiguity strategic
ambiguity means that while the u.s
provides military equipment and some
military training to taiwan it's never
said explicitly whether it would or
would not come to taiwan's defense if it
were attacked by china that's been the
case for some four decades now
the rationale behind strategic ambiguity
has been that it creates on the one hand
enough fear in china's mind that an
attack on taiwan would bring an american
military response that china will be
reluctant to move while on the other
hand not giving taiwan such a flat
assurance america would come to its
rescue that it does something too bold
and reckless and brings on the very
fight the us is trying to avoid
now though some are arguing that the
time for strategic ambiguity has ended
and that the growing threat from china
calls instead for strategic clarity that
is these voices argue the u.s should
make it clear it will come to taiwan's
defense why well the argument goes china
is a different country now than it was
four decades ago it's far stronger
militarily and much more assertive in
international affairs moreover u.s
actions in recent years in places such
as afghanistan and syria raised doubts
internationally about whether the u.s
will stick up for its friends under
those circumstances it's argued china
might become reckless and miscalculate
american resolve by thinking it could
move on taiwan without consequence and
the way to head off such chinese
thinking is to be clear not ambiguous
president biden caused a diplomatic stir
a few days ago when he suggested at a
town hall meeting that he actually is
moving away from strategic ambiguity
asked whether the us would come to
taiwan's defense if it were attacked he
said yes there's a commitment to do that
later though the white house walked back
that comment there is no change in our
policy our defense relationship with
taiwan is guided by the taiwan relations
act still china was quite unhappy with
that biden comment which just shows that
moving away from strategic ambiguity to
strategic clarity would make already
tense relations with china even worse
and some fear taiwan would think it has
a kind of blank check to be as
provocative with china as it would like
so put this debate on the growing list
of china issues the biden administration
has to tackle